boom I can't [ __ ] talk dammit hi guys
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome No hello everybody my name
is markiplier and uh [ __ ] it
ah throughout the history of my channel
so many a booth throughout the history
of my channel so many people have made
fan art of me fan art of things that
I've done you can catalog the experience
of my channel through Oh Damon oh [ __ ] I
broke it can't withstand markiplier huh
no neither can anyone else so anyway
that was weird but we're gonna ignore
the fact that the recording cut out
don't don't mind your thing all my I I
know what I'm doing I've been a youtuber
for years I'm very professional alright
so the point stands is that I'm honored
that so many people love to make fan art
of me and want to do these things and I
feel bad because I can't see all of it
so there's a whole bunch of fan art
that's been cataloged in the deviant
arts fan art page the markiplier fans
deviantART there's a ton of stuff here
they're their groups that are closed
just over time they filled up so much
and then there's a digital art that's
open there's traditional art there's
just a whole bunch of stuff that's here
and I'm honored that so many people just
love to make this stuff this is awesome
I love this yeah and you can just go
through it and through it and through it
and you see all of this amazing stuff
that's really good and just so many
different creative things here and like
so many ways that people make fan art oh
oh it's tiny box Tina oh that's so cool
oh and this is the same person did fan
art of my mom here our little group our
little group stuff here yeah it's so
cool to see but it dawned on me that I
have never made fan art myself I may
have doodled but I've never specifically
made fan art and then have been brave
enough to send it to my favorite
creators or youtubers or whoever you
call them and so today I am going to
make fan art of some of my favorite
YouTube channels they're by no means my
favorite so don't get any favoritism
ideas get plenty of favoritism ideas
random by favoring if they're not on
this list
I must hate them forever and
ever okay anyway now that I got that out
of the way so don't buy into it like if
I don't have if I didn't do fan out to
someone doesn't mean I hate him it means
that I could do it in another episode if
this actually turns out to be
interesting but until like it's at that
point I'm not gonna worry about it so
I'm gonna try to get through this in the
first place so I've got three channels
that I want to make fan art of right now
the first one is Kurt's kesaji which is
in a nutshell if you've ever seen their
videos or if you've never seen their
videos they're [ __ ] amazing and
usually scary as [ __ ] but there's well
animated videos where they talk about
science facts space facts humanity
different ideas like thought experiments
kind of like the infotainment style
animations but really high quality done
so I love them and one of the cute
things that they got is this little bird
guy so I'm gonna make I'm gonna draw me
in mspaint I could do Photoshop but I I
can't actually draw very well so I'm
gonna use a tool that's reflective of my
ability and that's mspaint
okay I'm gonna do something artistic
here I'm gonna use negative space
negative is that a ghost all right so
what I'm gonna do is I am going to make
it in rayon well this Sisson okay I
don't know how to use this hahaha
there we go okay not gonna do that
alright so the thing about this little
guy is it's a super cute little bird and
they're made in the same south so I'm
gonna make a markiplier version of their
bird oh it's not gonna be good but it's
gonna be something oh this is turning
out wonderfully excellent use of
negative space oh man I should have
probably pulled up a reference or
something but yeah why would I do that
I'm I'm not the kind of guy that just
needs a reference or anything give them
nice [ __ ] brown eyes that's good they're
an expressive eyebrow that's pretty good
maybe just the hint of the other eye on
across oh yeah whatever I'm not gay I'm
not gonna go back and I would I would
put black hair but it doesn't make sense
so I'm gonna put red hair just because
that's just indicative of what I will
now just looks like a chicken I messed
up I meant to make this you know
something
I made a chicken I didn't I didn't
realize that I was gonna be making a
chicken err but uh I think I did get
some shading shading some big epic
pectoral muscles please I'm gonna try it
out to make these look like boobs I
think I made them look like boobs
damn it at the tail feather got a jet
engine on I've got jet engines on me
yeah I know I know I'm pretty cool like
that fire shooting out the back
not that fire fire yeah that looks good
looks like I got boobs and a minigun
here but I did my best so I'm just gonna
write a message I wanna just in case
anybody couldn't tell her sick oh that's
not how you spell it is it well I'm
gonna try what I got in my head and then
compare it to the original Curt cig
Ignace no that's not right at all well I
should have tried here I did try that's
the problem I actually tried here I'm
using a mouse and I almost just pulled
my entire computer off of its rack but
either way I've got that so that's good
so I got that that's the thing cool
right got it all right okay so you'd
think this was done right
perfection mastered Oh oh no oh no oh no
no no no no I made this and it's nice
and it's lovely but it's not done
because I need to get them to notice it
hey kurzgesagt I really love your videos
so I made my own little bird hope you
like it so I don't mean to make fun of
anything I'm not trying to make fun of
people that do this on Twitter but this
is what you guys do you are brave enough
to literally make something and send it
to someone so I have to do the same if I
actually want to do this so I'm gonna
send them my boob chicken and I hope
they don't think that I'm making fun of
them because I really like it and keep
making awesome videos yeah that's it
right that's that's how you do it I
really love your videos so I made my own
little burp hope you liked it and keep
making awesome videos PS I really tried
it this
please don't make fun of me it doesn't
help my case that I've misspelled the
goddamn name I'm not an [ __ ] I just I
didn't know how to spell it I did it
yeah I did it I made my first fan art
yeah sound the alarm
release the balloons Wow alright now I
gotta make another one okay so the next
on my list uh someone that I go to all
the time for entertainment is explosive
and if you don't know about explosion
they've been making a webcomic for a
long long time so I love their videos
they pump out animations all the time I
love their cyanide and Happiness show I
love it all I look forward to their
stuff all the time I'm gonna make my own
comic yeah yeah pretty good huh I'm
gonna make my own one alright so what I
need to do is I need to just wipe the oh
[ __ ] I need to wipe the slate clean I'm
not gonna do this alright so if you
don't know about explosion if your bra's
seeing their comics before in fact you
don't even need to look up their comics
cuz you're about to find out what it is
I need to make a a few boxes here that's
good yeah that's good boo boo and okay
now I just have to be funny it's gonna
be rough ooh boy I'm gonna make it in
crayon again that's the best that I can
do for someone to make guy this is like
this guy I got the square body he's like
hey hey little sass to him little sass
to him excuse my scar on my mouth Jesus
crying that's not good I can't draw I'm
not funny either these guys buddy over
here doing his thing he's he's very he's
not sassy it is the least
sassy possible Jesus Christ oh my god
that is that oh jeez okay all right then
let's see hey buddy why long face why
the long face buddy and then wait hang
on genius about to happen
these sassy legs in here sassy
broken legs lot of that spilling out
amongst to see least sassy possible
gotta get the knife in there just like
all my other ideas it just sub our ends
in death will puddle and then for the
final one yep yep can't get much
gigabytes worse than this huh he's
[ __ ] coming oh boy oh boy
arm sticking out of the frame a little
bit oh man Oh what did I make
what have I made what if I made I have
no idea what I made I I don't know what
I made but I made it so that's a thing
Tabata so save that save that gotta save
that explosive a murder fanart uh yeah
pretty good yeah it's good I like that
that's pretty good
I'm gonna do that I'm going to tweet at
them he explodes them been such a long
time fan of your work always makes me
laugh and I look forward every animation
well and I look forward to everything
May
this for you hey explosive been such a
longtime fan of your work always makes
me laugh and I look forward to
everything made this for you and Boop
yay I did it I get my second fan art I
did it yeah I got it oh man
let's see we're happy about that alright
so I got one more so I'm a huge fan of
h3h3
love them in person love them and online
they're they're super cool guys and I'm
just like a huge fan of Ethan Aniela
they're great people you know I've hung
out with them in person and I'm just a
big fan of their work I look forward to
their videos all the time so I want to
make them fan art to cap it all off and
then you know it'll be pretty cool so
I'm gonna do that I'm gonna do that not
exactly sure of what but I'm gonna make
this but I need I need I need to work in
negative space again I feel like I feel
like I feel like I'm most comfortable
when I'm in negative space so I'm gonna
make I'm gonna start with the the beam
it looks like a beanie yeah something
like that squish that face down a little
bit squish it what am i drawing a wizard
here that doesn't see that that's not a
smile don't think that's a smile that's
it's not a smile and try to that's the
mouth get the nice nose in there get a
nice nose Nosal region I want like him
creeping out from underneath what am I
making
oh my god what color has eyes not blue
I'm willing to bet they're not blue but
you know what I'm gonna go for it Oh
feeling a lot less confident about this
one than I was whoa whoa this might be
my worst stuff might be my worst one
okay so I got a good ela and yellows got
the red beanie going on there oh my god
looks like a murderer just creeping up
mine I'm a drawn the puppet from five
nights at Freddy's geez
um well let's let's commit let's commit
to this I've somehow made this extremely
creepy I highly doubt that Ella has pure
white eyes also I have no idea where I'm
going with this with the the triangle
ear and the triangle nose but
it's briquette a wave and hi hello hello
that's that's that's nation not mash oh
boy Clark do that I know how to use
Emma's paid very well I know all the ins
and outs of Emma's paint for some
[ __ ] reason I don't know why and then
I'm gonna write just in case it wasn't
obvious this is Ella this is Ethan the
wizard and I just like to say scream on
random occasions when I celebrate so
yeah that's good
sorry about the hand and the everything
ela sorry about turning you into a
majestic wizard with an epic neckbeard
Ethan so yeah that's good right that's
good
probably good I'm gonna save that I'm a
little bit shy about sending this one
off huh I don't want to do this oh boy I
know you get a lot of fan art but I just
wanted to send this your way because I
love your videos and you guys I really
hope that no one thinks I'm being
facetious about this because I'm really
trying here this is like the best that I
can do it's the best that I could it
this this is the best that I can do I
mean I'm not joking about that when I
say that that's the best that I can do I
am NOT an artist if I was photoshopping
things which I'm gonna do I'd be better
at that but I'm not I'm not an artist I
do the best that I can let's say this
your way because I love ya I love you
our video oh my god I love your videos
and you guys okay side-by-side
comparison just so that I can you know
get this in here you see you see yeah
it's an uncanny resemblance that's it's
it's weird how life like my fan art is
so yeah yeah let's bring in hey I did I
send my first fan arts I did it I feel
good about myself I hope they don't hate
it I hope they don't hate me ooh ah ah
dab away the awkwardness so anyway that
is markiplier spanner
just you know did you uh uh uh what have
I done so anyway yeah I I love these
people a lot I love them a lot I I
really do appreciate it I'm not doing
this to make fun of them or anyone that
makes fan art at all
I love fan art I love the fact that you
guys make it I want to see it all and I
want you guys to be able to show it to
me it's just so hard with so many people
talking to me all at once but I want to
see it so thank you all who has ever
made fan art and if you've never made
someone something or if you've never
made it never made some if you've never
made another human you know in your life
[ __ ] is a terrible joke so if you've
never made anything like this before
it's a really cool feeling because I
have genuine appreciation for what these
people do and I hope they understand
that through what I'm doing here and I
hope they understand I'm not making fun
of them so either way thank you
everybody so much for watching and thank
you once again for supporting me
throughout the entire time that I've
been on YouTube there are so many pieces
of fan art there's just so many an
endless amount you could go on for hours
and hours and hours just looking at all
the fan art and you would not get
through it but thank you guys for taking
the time to make it thank you everybody
I checked this deviantART every single
day just because I love it and I know I
should post more to Facebook and and
link more and I will but it's just it's
so heartwarming to see all the cool
stuff that comes out of the community so
let me know down the comments if you
want to see more cool stuff like this I
really want to do stuff like this I
really want to like make fan art of you
guys I want to be able to like go to
Twitter and say hey send me a picture of
yourself send me anything you want and
I'll make fan art of you guys and maybe
do this again and tweet it yeah the cool
creations that I make so thanks again
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]